who was the hardest player you had to
defend
hey lebron early lebron james well
actually i think jordan was the toughest
man so jordan
the reason i was talking about wizards
jordan [ __ ] yeah the first year was his
jordan not um not his last year yeah no
cause when he came back mid-season on
the wizards he still had it yeah he had
like a 50-point game he was there for
the whole season
i thought he came back mid season in the
first two and a half seasons with the
wizards so the first year was miss
season next year right next year was the
full season and then that last year was
when things got really average like he
was he was he was not jordan but that
first year came back he averaged 25. no
i remember that people would be
forgetting and that team almost i
remember they had like a tear i mean it
was like him and rip hamilton and like
jaleel white and it was if i was a rough
team i used to play with him on 2k all
the time yeah
i mean but then john is not running like
he used to be so
even then jordan was tough to defend i
mean the thing about jordan was you knew
what he was going to do you knew what he
was going to do
and he going he's going to get you all
you're going to pull up he on go left
pull up go fig right and you knew it was
coming
we're like lebron when i first started
god lebron like lebron i didn't really
know what he was going to do and he was
quite successful but it was still like
you know it wasn't as predictable which
made it a little harder but jordan i
knew exactly what he gonna do
and then kobe was pretty difficult i
mean those guys
you know those guys
but if i had to give it to one i would
probably say jordan
um and your and you and and maybe ty
with lebron and kobe lebron and cup i
mean you because were you were you with
the bulls when you had to defend jordan
i was with the bulls and one time
indiana oh wow
that's crazy yeah now i got to defend
this guy the whole city's [ __ ] with
him